[Music]
if you had told me 10 years ago that
you'll be playing spider-man in a movie
like this i would have been like you're
a liar oh it's just fizzing with
excitement you know it's like
coming into halftime when the game's
already going and you jumping in it's
like i gotta keep up i gotta keep up
he's been to space he's become
spider-man he's lost his mentor and now
his identity is revealed and all he
wants to do is graduate high school and
go to college i'm not sure that these
people
realize that i'm not in this movie i'm
not gonna burst their bubble for them
what are you looking forward to seeing
most in this film tonight well number
one my homies uh benedict cumberbatch
and benny wong gotta support the crew
got an email from kevin feige saying
it's fast becoming the wcu so i'll
i'll take that the wong cinematic
universe i like it i like it definitely
i get to play the grown-ups surrounded
by kids i can say that they're half my
age they are kids does ned get to get on
the action on this one oh my goodness
like you wouldn't believe ned and mj are
killing it
yes how did it feel to be web slinging
and flying high oh man it was so much
fun i love being able to do that stuff i
i'm not afraid of heights in that way so
i feel really good about it now what's
the difference between this jay jonah
jameson and the one you played
previously only the hair really mr dale
is truly a man of science
makes the world go round now do you have
a favorite mcu moment in spider-man
through your journey i like when we're
in the bathroom i think we're in the
bathroom together my really cool like
nick fury moment is completely
undermined by a toilet flushing how does
he inspire you i bring him to red carpet
events
so who are you excited to see tonight
uh the kid to play spider-man whatever
his name is and
you know the 75 bad guys
when i first heard the idea for the
movie i thought this is impossible at
the time i was like there's no way that
they could pull this off there's no way
that they'll be able to bring these
villains back into this universe and
make it make sense
but they did oh it's always good to be a
bad guy it's good being bad it's great
to be a part of it
see some old friends see some new
friends you know i'm just ready
ready for all of you to know what i know
[Music]
you